[Musique]
bienvenue à tous pour ce nouveau numéro
de Paris sa clé le mag un numéro solaire
enfin surtout dans nos reportages avec
déjà le Solar Decathlon c'est la
première fois que la France accueille ce
concours international nous sommes à
Versailles des équipes universitaires
venu de 16 pays ont imaginé les maisons
de demain vous allez les découvrir nous
allons aussi vous emmener à bord de
l'éol un prototype fabriqué par ecosolar
Brez il roule à l'énergie solaire et les
premiers essais de la saison ont eu lieu
sur le circuit de Versailles
avoir des idées c'est bien les financers
c'est mieux c'est tout l'enjeu de Paris
sa clé invest ce rendez-vous a permis à
de jeunes entrepreneurs de rencontrer
des investisseurs vous entendrez leurs
témoignage à suivre aussi le festival
futur en scène au proto 204 cet espace
d'échange et d'innovation multiplie les
initiatives sans oublier enfin le blocne
pour revenir sur toute l'actualité du
site ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
quel habitat pour demain et bien la
maison du futur sera solaire et elle
ressemblera peut-être à celle-ci c'est
l'un des prototypes présentés dans le
cadre du Solar Decathlon cette
compétition internationale a été lancée
aux États-Unis en 2002 et c'est la
première fois que la France accueille ce
concours nous sommes à Versailles 20
projets ont été retenus 16 pays
qualifiés les étudiants ont eu 18 mois
pour concevoir et construire leur maison
solaire vous allez tout de suite suite
les
découvrir le solur décathlon est une
compétition universitaire internationale
mise au point par les Américains au
début des années 2000 par algor lui-même
qui consiste à faire concourir des
équipes d'architecture des équipes
d'étudiants pardon en architecture et en
ingénierie afin de concevoir l'habitat
de demain cette compétition a lieu tous
les 2 ans elle existe aux États-Unis en
Chine mais aussi en Europe depuis 2010
ici c'est la première fois en France
après deux éditions espagnoles et vous
avez derrière moi les 20 prototypes qui
sont en en voie d'achèvement ils ont été
construits par les étudiants eux-mêmes
et seront demain soir tous
fonctionnels il y a à peu près 800 850
personnes derrière moi moyenne d'âge 22
ans une majorité
d'étudiants venant de toutes écoles 16
nationalités différentes trois
continents c'est un solar Décathlon
solar parce que toute l'énergie
nécessaire au chauffage à l'eau chaude à
la ventilation y compris la mobilité
électrique des habitants est fourni par
le solaire et uniquement par le solaire
Décathlon parce qu'il s'agit de 10
épreuves si d'entre elles jugé par des
plus grands noms de de jury
internationaux trois qui sont des
mesures fait dans chacun des prototypes
et enfin une sur
l'innovation
ce que vous avez derrière moi ce sont
des prototypes d'habitat qui fournissent
pas loin de deux fois tous leurs besoins
de consommation et qui fonctionne déjà
avec la douche la machine à laver la
cuisine ce sont de véritables habitats
pour la plupart d'ailleurs pas des
maisons mais des tranches
d'immeubl vous êtes en face du prototype
fileas qui a été réalisé par l'équipe
nantaise pour le concours Solar des con
on a réhabilité ce bâtiment suivant
trois concepts d'abord réinvestir
l'existant utiliser au maximum la
matière existante et le réel ensuite
réintroduire l'agriculture en ville
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que vous voyez
une serre sur le toit symbole de cette
agriculture au sein des villes et au
sein même des bâtiments et mixer les
usages que ce soit au sein du bâtiment
ou au niveau des milieux sociaux et des
générations se faire côtoyer des gens
différents
être ici c'est déjà l'aboutissement d'un
long processus un processus de 18 mois
de travail pour des équipes qui ont été
sélectionné à l'automne 2012 et qui ont
peu à peu développé leur projet chaque
ve donne lieu à un prix et celui qui a
eu le plus de points à le Grand Prix de
Solard
[Musique]
descatlon après la maison solaire le
véhicule solaire EOL a fait ses premiers
essais de la saison sur le circuit de
Versailles satori ce prototype a été
fabriqué par ecosolar Brez il s'entraîne
pour le World Challenge qui aura lieu en
Australie cette course met en
compétition une cquantaine de voitures
électriques alors vous me direz quel est
le lien entre un projet breton et le
site de Paris sa-clé tout simplement
l'innovation nous avons rencontré
Jean-Luc florau c'est le président de
l'association écosolar
Brez
c'est un véhicule électrique doté de 6
m² de cellules solaires de 21 kg de
lithiumon de batterie de litomignon
c'est on peut rouler même lorsque le
temps le soleil n'est pas au rendez-vous
on a à peu près 3 3h à 4 He d'autonomie
sur batterie et sinon lorsque le soleil
est au rendez-vous on peut rouler
uniquement grâce à l'énergie solaire à
55 km/h avec un pilote donc de 80 kg et
le véhicule en lui-même fait euh 188 kg
ce que l'on cherche à démontrer avant
tout c'est comment se déplacer donc
travers une mobilité verte en minimisant
l'énergie pour se
déplacer on a choisi de venir dans le
dans le département des des ivelines euh
sur euh sur une invitation qui qui nous
a été faite par par movo et par vdcom
qui est
l'Institut dédié à la nouvelle mobilité
au véhicules décarboné et communicant
donc vdcom qui va se construire sur le
site même de du circuit de de Versailles
satori qui d'ici 3 ans devrait
accueillir plus de 300 chercheurs donc
travaillant sur la nouvelle mobilité et
le le département des evelines est un
département qui s'investit beaucoup dans
cette dans cette nouvelle mobilité on
commence nos tests sur une piste qui est
une une piste plutôt remarquable
puisqu'elle a un revêtement qui est
proche de celui de de la Stuart Highway
que l'on empruntera sur 3000 km entre
Darwin et adelaï en Australie un des
aspects qui a séduit movo et et Vcom
c'est que l'on développe des
technologies par exemple la partie
communiquante du du véhicule comportte
des technologies qui sont largement à la
hauteur de ce que l'on peut trouver sur
les véhicules qui sont aujourd'hui
présentés sur le marché entre autes par
rapport à la à la gestion de
l'information et à l'optimisation de
l'énergie à bord du véhicule
électrique c'est le lieu où il faut être
le proto 204 se veut l'incarnation de
l'esprit Paris saclé et propose des
conférences des festivals des
expositions dernière en date le festival
futur en scène 4 jours de programmation
autour des nouvelles technologie et du
numérique l'objectif est toujours le
même réunir différentes communautés
autour de projets ludiques et
scientifiques ronand James le
responsable du proto 204 revient sur ces
4 jours de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
festival dans le cadre du festival futur
encienne le Pr 94 a proposé 4 jours de
programmation du 16 au 19 juin pour
connecter les communautés de Paris saclé
autour du numérique et les nouvelles
innovations
technologiques qu'on a souhaité faire
autour de ces 4 jours c'est d'avoir des
journées thématiques sur le made with
startup made with makers made with
Community et le dernier jour était dédié
aux artistes pour les relations à r
science pour nous c'était important
parce que l'occasion de passer des
ateliers de préfiguration avec les
parten qui nous ont aidé à monter le
lieu qui est le proto 104 à un moment
plus d'action et un moment vitrine aussi
pour montrer l'ensemble des innovateurs
des acteurs qui sont sur pareil sa
clé chose qui a rapidement marqué les
les esprits en général quand les gens
arrivaient c'était les installations
interactives qu'on a pu proposer une
installation pour plonger et explorer la
surface de Mars à travers une interface
interactive donc ça aussi qui marche
très très bien et l'autre partie qui
était pas du tout technologique là pour
le coup ce sont les les conférences avec
notamment Thomas boudalier qui est
entrepreneur qui a cofondé neoland qui a
été racheté très significatif par par
Adob et qui est vraiment un beau
parcours d'entrepreneur et qui a qui a
généreusement partagé avec humour en
plus ses conseils pour toutes les
futures start-ups qui sont dans sur le
territoire une des actions par exemple
c'est dans le cadre de la Journée des
makers où on a eu les fameuses
imprimantes 3D mais on a aussi des
conférences sur les FabLab et les
nouvelles valeurs que ça créé dans le
cadre de la RD et les entreprises donc
des thématiques assez larg l'ensemble de
ces acteurs qui ont participé à cette
journée nous a permis de bien anticiper
maintenant le la création d'un hacker
space donc un lieu de fabrication à à la
taille du lieu donc assz assez intime
mais de comment est-ce que ces nouveaux
lieux ces nouveaux programmes permettent
de rassembler des porteurs de projets
qui qui vont créer ensemble des
nouvelles choses et puis sûrement se
rencontrer et puis créer qu'on espère
montrer l'année prochaine en 2015 à
futur
enseignement
avoir des projets concevoir des
prototypes c'est bien mais ensuite il
faut les financer Paris sa clé veut
développer les synergies entre les
jeunes créateurs et les investisseurs
d'où cette journée de rencontre
organisée à palzo le Paris saclé invest
des entreprises ont été sélectionnées
par un jury seul 10 d'entre elles ont
été retenues ensuite il a fallu
convaincre avec un grand oral et en
face- à faceace Bruno Duval le président
de l'association finances et technologie
nous en dit
plus
[Musique]
il s'agit d'uneune journée de rencontre
d'affaires entre des créateurs de
start-up et des investisseurs en
amorçage spécialisés en
amorçage ce sont des projets présents du
plateau de sacclet de la du périmètre de
le PPS l'établissement public Paris
saclé qui fait partie des des financeurs
et des acteurs avec qui nous avons
travaillé pour l'organisation de cette
cette
journée les créateurs ont un planning de
rendez-vous avec des investisseurs pour
les aider à renforcer leurs fonds
propres pour que leurs projets puissent
prendre la dimension nécessaire à une
croissance convenable et internationale
global comme toute société devrait
l'être
aujourd'hui monter un rendez-vous face à
face avec des investisseurs c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas si simple
que ça et donc on l'offre aujourd'hui au
créateur je suis le président de la
Société fitle la technologie fitle
permet de numériser tous les vêtements
en 3D qui existent sur tous les sites
qui existe
actuellement on récupère des
informations qui nous permettent après
de recréer le vêtement en 3D uite on
l'utilisateur en 3D à partir de 4 photos
et à partir de ça on recrée
l'utilisateur en 3D du coup
l'utilisateur peut essayer sur lui des
vêtements en
3D on est très heureux d'avoir pu
remporter ce prix qui montre en fait que
l'idée également rencontre petit à petit
son
public plusieurs des associés de la
boîte sont issu de l'École polytechnique
qui est sur le campus saclclé je suis
moi même diplômé à mur spécialisé de
central Paris qui va rejoindre Paris
saclé donc c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir cet écosystème là qui non
seulement soutient l'innovation et qui
en plus regroupe en un le même endroit
les meilleures écoles françaises pour
créer un pôle de compétitivité au niveau
mondial on sait qu'historiquement on a
toujours dans les 3 à 6 mois au moins 20
% des des des projets présentés qui
lèvent et qui vont se développer alors
soit ils vont se développer eux-mêmees
ont continue leur croissance on a
plusieurs projets qui ont continué qui
sont devenus des sociétés de bonne
taille et puis d'autres projets qui se
font racheter et qui vont par des grands
groupes industriels ou ou ou ce genre de
chos et qui vont poursuivre d'une autre
façon leur leur développement
avant de nous quitter retour sur les
temps forts de ces dernières semaines à
Paris sa clé avec le summercamp 2014 une
école d'été pour tous les étudiants qui
ont envie d'entreprendre ils ont eu 5
jours pour s'imerger dans les lieux les
plus innovants du campus le thème retenu
cette année était la ville les robots et
nous 60 étudiants ont pu participer à
cette belle aventure humaine à noté
aussi la présentation du projet
architecturale de la maison d'initiation
et de sensibilisation aux sciences ce
projet porté par la Région Île-de-France
en partenariat avec la diagonale Paris
saclé l'Université Paris Sud et le CNRS
s'adresse aux jeunes objectif qui
s'intéresse aux études et aux carrières
dans le domaine des sciences
expérimentales tout un programme enfin
ce classement des usines les premières
usines de France publiées par l'usine
nouvelles les meilleures usines mais
aussi les meilleurs centres de recherche
et de développement et dans ce top ten 5
RND sont de Paris saclé dont celui du
numéro 1 Renault Technocentre aguill
encour 3e place PSA Peugot au Citroën à
vill coublé juste après et toujours à
ville coublé Talès Alcatel Luc noosé
décroche la 6e place et Sagem Massi
ferme le banc au 10e rang voilà c'est
déjà la fin de ce Paris saclé Le Mag
merci de votre attention on se retrouve
très vite pour d'autres projets
innovants et écologiques à
bientôt
[Musique]